hey there i'm colby rebel I am a
professional psychic medium my name is
Elizabeth self I'm a private
investigator with cane associates and my
job today is to figure out which one of
these guys committed a crime
[Music]
P I versus psychic who can get it right
psychic I'm a little nervous this is
this was weird
I'm a little nervous here we go I have a
misdemeanor for bootlegging alcohol in
the state of Utah
honestly I don't I don't see anyone here
they all look really nice to me actually
this should be really fun I mean I stood
to see what is gonna happen here with
these guys I'm gonna start with you hi
there what's your name
Blake Kolby nice to meet you like what's
the capital Utah holy city I wasn't in
Utah but that's where I got in trouble
it's a whole thing so you weren't in
Utah I was in Utah when I got in trouble
but I wasn't like visiting Utah I was in
Wyoming but we were going from Casper to
Foley and how could you get in trouble
with Utah because I was in Salt Lake
Susan Utah but we were I was staying in
Casper I mean I'm not from there but so
I'm guessing moonshine you didn't know
what you had with you not really now why
Dayton er n't I just heard we were going
to Salt Lake so I hopped in the crib
hopped in the in the truck what kind of
trap it was a ford f350 color maroon but
it had like a gold trim buddy
uh no just it's hotter than what it is
okay all right thank you Boyd all right
sweet cheeks okay cupcake what's your
name I'm Emily hey Emily I'm gonna shake
your hand say hello all right Emily what
were you doing in Utah I was on my way
to Idaho to film a documentary and then
you had bootlegging how'd that happen
it's kind of a crazy story yeah they're
all crazy it seems we were just you know
carrying a lot of carrying horses and a
lot of things and we're very large very
large toe you just happen to have
bootleg I guess I'm the Cowboys did ya
but we were all kind of together what
was the alcohol you were bootlegging I
really don't know so how did you have a
misdemeanor well we were all kind of
there
they kind of just put it on all of us
and that way did you have to go to jail
no okay
I'm that's great thank you hi there
what's your name I'm Nate hey Nate how
you doing good how are you I'm good I'm
good what was the alcohol you were
bootlegging wine what kind of wine red
wine what happened did you have to go to
jail yeah I spent the night in jail what
happened when when you spent the night
in jail uh it was just for like
processing but then after the night they
let me out with uh just kind of like a
slap on the wrist essentially did you
have to pay your fine yeah how much $300
so what kind of car were you in
I Drive a Hyundai Accent what color
silver who was with you just me and so
what is the loan you talk about wine the
law it's I think alcohol in general you
can't have more than three point two
percent per volume but that's different
in Nevada so I could buy it in Nevada
but then as soon as I cross state lines
I was breaking the law so how did you
get pulled over though because they
would have had to pull you over first
I had a busted taillight ah-ha which
taillight my right taillight uh-huh and
then he came over he checked my license
and he saw I just had three bottles of
wine sitting in my passenger seat and
he's like that's against the law so then
he took you to jail for it well he
escorted me to the station and then I
spent the night there
for processing something and they're
like all right you're not from here and
you can go was your family upset they
were upset that I spent the night in
jail but that was about it okay thank
you a few of these shady McGrady's back
here have been given a fib or two I will
be honest and you can kind of tell
through their energy their energy shifts
and you can kind of tell if they're
creating a thought before they speak you
can tell with the shifting of the eyes
which is a subconscious reaction to a
question that they don't know the answer
to Nate so far is the most convincing
but almost too convincing cuz I'm almost
a little worried that he's rehearsed his
little story so we will we will see we
will see I've got one suspect left oh
I'm excited to have him sit
what's your name hi Josh how you doing
good ok so what were you doing in Utah
visiting some friends and where were you
when you got got busted on the border
between Wyoming and Utah and why did you
get busted I got pulled over for
speeding okay it's a really long boring
road right there and had a bunch of beer
in the backseat okay so then why was the
baron of vaccine an issue apparently in
Utah you can't have outside alcohol how
would they know it's outside I have no
idea what happened after that they
pulled me over
ah-ha give me a speeding ticket and then
they wanted to take me to jail okay I
actually gave them like a I'm from
Wyoming instead like can I just do
something else and so then they gave me
a court case well what else did you do
their little song and dance
no they just sent me a court date so you
had to go back to Utah for court and
then they gave you a misdemeanor yeah
and did you pay a fine they did how much
was the fine I wasn't knowing that's
expensive Wow did you have a hard time
with that yeah so what were you doing in
Wyoming at the time working in a minor
how long ago was this this would have
been C about 20-ish years ago but in
time you didn't know you couldn't have
alcohol not across state lines so no
other previous trips did you take out
cause don't everything happen you just
happen to get caught this time yeah and
none of your friends told you no I just
never really thought of it as a big deal
okay all right thank you yeah yeah okay
I'm gonna ask them one more question
blade have a seat just one more quick
question yeah okay I just want you to
look at me and say I have a misdemeanor
for bootlegging in Utah I have a
misdemeanor for bootlegging in Utah I
have a misdemeanor for bootlegging in
Utah hey guys I have a misdemeanor for
bootlegging in Utah I have a misdemeanor
for bootlegging in Utah okay all right
thank you very much I'm gonna need
another minute here and I'm excited to
come back with my results well let's
start with you sir all right
senator to police well there's a state
trooper and then there was from Wyoming
and one from Utah
why was he one from Wyoming there was
right right on the border and they just
converged on you yeah interesting
all right so how old were you at the
time 25 and was it your first time ever
being pulled over no I've been pulled
over for speeding before well is that
the only thing you've ever really done
yeah you're never really a troublemaker
other than that not that I've ever been
caught with did you guys catch that look
there's a high road not that you've ever
been gone okay so why did you get caught
why do they pull you over speeding how
fast are you speeding I won about 10
over 10 over normally they give you
about a 15 15 mile an hour leeway I'm
Utah nah we're just driving through
visiting family visiting friends okay
well I'm gonna go ahead and move on to
the next person all the questions I have
for you I may pull you back down here
come sit down here
what's your name Nate Nate tell me about
how guilty you are I guess I'm pretty
guilty I mean I get in trouble where was
the wine sitting and my passenger seat
on the floor just rolling around
I had like put like my jacket in between
them so they wouldn't like Clank up
against each other but they were just
there oh so you had more than one wine
bottle at three what kind of red wine
okay just picked out three cheap bottles
of red wine yeah and was your family
with you
no I was by myself in the car I Drive a
Hyundai Accent how long ago was this
this was two years ago I'm done talking
to you give me the next one I'm gonna
pull you guys back down here probably
for another one hello hello and what's
your name
Emily Emily tell me about how you are a
very naughty girl I mean first of all
very quiet tell me it was it was alcohol
right says alcohol okay tell me about it
well this one guy was bootlegging
whiskey I think it was could you try any
no because we were on our way there and
then it got taken before we were able to
actually get to the destination so he
brought his funky little supply that he
made how much was it I don't remember I
never really saw it they were just kind
of like unloading it from the car but it
was like enough for I mean how many
people were there maybe like 20 people
they were probably like three horse
trailers and a couple other trucks and
you're just kind of a part of it yeah I
mean I was the doctor wasn't like riding
horses or anything have you ever been in
trouble was pulled over any other time I
was at a park when it was dark out once
and was told to leave with a boyfriend
we're just sitting on a bench I bet you
guys were just sitting on a van it's
dark are you a little nervous yeah I am
actually my legs are shaking yeah when
you were polar was just how many police
were there I think there are about two
there was one like pulled us all over
and then another one kind of I guess was
driving by and that thing please do were
they all kind of stopping make it worse
and then they took the alcohol okay well
go ahead I've got a nice little talk to
you I'm not sure about her she seems
just a little bit nervous in general and
I've come across these people before all
right
come sit down last but not least
definitely the tallest well I'm
Elizabeth what's your name
like so now you guys took alcohol can
alcohol there was one vodka bottle and
it was like two whisky balls but it
wasn't all like bottom shelf like not
good stuff you put it in a toolbox
they did they did I wasn't in my car I
was riding along so you didn't actually
get in trouble your friends then we all
got in trouble they took us all we all
got a mist in here rubbing your pants
you've been jiggling your legs I have
that I get sweaty whenever under the
light you talk to really awesome people
you might be lying to maybe why did you
guys put the stuff in a toolbox I'd have
no idea that was it was not Mike that's
just where it was how did the police
find him - a lot they searched pretty
heavily like they took a fall out they
had us in we were standing in a ditch
and literally just in the ditch on the
side of the road they have sell out and
they searched through everything they
were like pulling everything out of the
glove box everything looking they were
looking for drugs why would they be
looking for drugs did you guys look
questionable they just took us out and
start searching like everything did yeah
how late was this this was at like 11
o'clock the morning 11 o'clock in the
morning they pull you over because
you're I guess we're speeding or
whatever yes you're speeding that was
not it I did not end up being the
problem and didn't really seem like they
were worried about it
I'm so so fun why they're searching you
I mean if it's a random pull over
because your speed maybe we looked
shady I mean maybe you were like doing
this thing when they like here's the
thing about you you seem like one of
these guys who like always seems like
they're lying no matter what they're
saying oh man because like you know I I
get the vibe that maybe there are parts
of this story that are true I'm not sure
but you act really guilty go ahead Sam
Erica I didn't believe this guy at first
at first I'm like he's super nervous but
then he seems like he might be actually
just one of those people who like tells
a nervous story or just doesn't look
really truthful you look truthful at
first until I started talking I feel
like I have it between two people here's
the problem I never listen to my gut
on these sorts of things because I'll
start questioning be like well this one
seemed a little bit nervous and this one
seemed like that but generally if I
listen to my gut it's true so I think I
know who it is
all right now we are going to write down
our predictions on a piece of paper hers
may be more factual than mine but let's
give it a shot here I wouldn't say that
so I'm confident between two people but
I'm a little bit torn it's pretty tough
I hope I'm confident and I was torn
between two people as well so either
they're really really good liars or we
got we got the right one here the same
one we both think Nate so let's see if
Nate just was he was my second one no I
did not think him I did yeah I was torn
between him and me
so the real story is I was living in
Utah at the time we're we actually
bootlegged it quite often so we would
we've gone on dozens of runs because
it's cheaper to get alcohol in Wyoming
that it is in Utah and we had very set
rules for how to do it like go in and
then either go to a movie in town or
something so if the cops saw you they
would lose track of you and well we
broke our own rules
and we just went up and straight across
the border and then an undercover sting
happening that weekend and so they
pulled us over
they'd filmed us loading up the back of
the car for a 4th of July party so
there's like five cops behind us then an
unmarked car from Nevada that is the
pole see this seems like a totally
unbelievable story that is like so how
did that all happen together yeah so so
that's why they pulled us over right on
the border and they had Utah and Wyoming
police there but we came back the next
day with my brother's truck and pulled
it off cuz we did a swap at an old movie
theater downtown's that we knew about so
we came in bought all that alcohol I put
it in his truck he went and went over
and then when I came back across the
same cops pulled they started pulling me
over again and then they stopped rolled
up next to me and just kind of looked at
me and pulled off and so we got away to
the next day my name is Josh I have a
misdemeanor for bootlegging alcohol in
the state
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]